speaking of friends in this business we
lost a great an icon i am a mustache i
am heartbroken absolutely and it was a
shock yeah and it was right before i got
here today you know it came across the
wire and everybody you know obviously uh
he wasn't open about his diagnosis and
uh we're talking about nor mcdonald's
who you know is from my home country
also a fellow canadian
he's he gave me some of my favorite
moments ever on snl and he was just so
funny so pure so authentic so real
and i mentioned it tonight on the show
because i thought it was so fitting on a
day with such great loss in the world of
comedy that we here on agt are
celebrating comedy with two comedians in
the final and i thought you know in
honor of this great loss
you know maybe this is a tribute
to norm mcdonald's
howie
talk to me about
your reaction overall and then if you
had to pick somebody that takes it all
who is that person
there's a couple of good chances i think
either the the last two have a great
chance and whether that's josh blue the
comedian or the northwell uh nurses
choir i think have a really good chance
of taking it but i have never i've been
here for 16 years and have never been
part of a finale where everybody
everybody roasts the occasion we've been
talking in past weeks
but we've been talking in past weeks and
on any given show somebody is crushed
under the pressure of live tv there's
always been something oh moment we
didn't have an uh-oh moment it was like
an oh wow moment every out of every
single act
tell me about that aiden moment aiden
obviously had a spectacular energized
wild scary performance and then simon
was on top of the table you seem to have
the same reaction you weren't on the
table but you felt the same way about
aiden's performance no no no
[Music]
i said i liked his last one better
better
you didn't think this one was
compare the two
it's really hard to compare because it's
a boy hanging from sheets spinning and i
as an agent as an agent as a judge
i was just thinking my age and because
we're the season finale right and i'm i
gotta
finish with you i gotta call my agent to
find out if i'm on
next year well so that's if he knows
what's good for him yeah that's the
priorities in my head right now but
speaking of aiden
you know it's it's hard to find so many
things to do unlike a song where you
could pick a new song unlike a comedian
who can write more material unlike a you
know a circus act which finds a new
stunt i felt like it looks really
similar and i thought that the smoothest
performance was the last one
in my opinion his last trick wasn't a
spectacular it wasn't good closing if i
was putting it together like a comedy
act that was not his biggest laugh to
close with yeah there was a moment where
i think we all thought it went wrong for
a second well that is called i know
because i've been here for years that's
called a death drop
we were terrified no but but if you've
watched death drops previously on our
show they have been like jaw-dropping
heart-shaking moments and it was a
little short and a little
i watched the setup but that's just me
and i'm not voting and i don't have
anything to do with who wins
you are a tough judge tonight i am told
you are i am a tough judge i saw and
spoke to heidi about a plunger on your
belly right how did this come about oh
because i don't like to stick my finger
i have an innie and i don't like to
stick my fingers in to get the lint out
so i use it it's a life hack
use it if you want to i use a plunger
and i my belly button and and i'll just
say it right now is probably the
freshest of anyone's on the show
there's an e.t scoop for you there's an
e.t scoop and we also learned something
else about you you have really good
friends friends so good they're willing
to plunge your belly button clean for
you that's right has always been there
for me heidi will call me sometimes in
the middle of night because is there
anything in your belly button i go why
she could because i can bring my plunger
tomorrow
like she doesn't even care to use mine
she brings a plunger to plunge my belly
that's friendship
[Music]